buongiorno a tutti sicuramente è un po
strano vedere su un palco come questo un
ufficiale di marina vederlo insieme a un
funzionario della protezione civile
probabilmente ci hanno messo per ultimi
questa mattina proprio perché sappiamo
gestire le emergenze 15 frapponiamo tra
tra voi e le due spaghi di prima e
quindi per gestire l'emergenza fame ma
non è di questo che vi parleremo vi
potrebbe aspettare vediamo se funziona
perfetto vi potreste aspettare che un
ufficiale di marina come richard gere
durante il film del film ufficiale
gentiluomo non è questo il caso anzi
quando ho provato il giorno del
matrimonio a fare questa cosa per poco
non mi staccavo la schiera aspettate
lasciatemi dire una cosa moglie amore
non è per colpa dura il vestito che era
troppo pesante
vedremo
no perché altrimenti stasera non posso
andare a casa potremmo parlare di
minaccia e minacce come quelle del
periodo della guerra fredda caccia a
ottobre rosso sommergibili nucleari o
quant'altro oppure potremmo parlare di
minacce odierne combattenti di al qaeda
o terroristi dell'isis o viceversa
e invece no parleremo di un altro tipo
di minaccia ma non meno subdola una
minaccia che non veste uniformi e non
porta non porta armi con sè sto parlando
della minaccia portata da coloro che
inquinano l'atmosfera in particolare in
questo caso il mare e se è vero che una
parte della dell'inquinamento marino
marino è dovuto a cause naturali
ricorderete tutti quanti lo tsunami del
la massa di materiali che furono portati
in mare e dopo il rientro delle acque ma
la gran parte del dell'inquinamento è
dovuto a cause a causa umane come il più
comune tipo di inquinamento delle acque
che è quello da idrocarburi home oppure
uno ancora più pericoloso è più subdolo
e a cui si rivolgono la maggior parte
delle organizzazioni internazionali
dell'ultimo nell'ultimo report che è
quello delle plastiche delle
microplastiche le seconde derivate dal
disfacimento delle prime
immaginate che il 65 per cento del
materiale che si trova sulle spiagge è
costituito da plastiche e questo è
soltanto la punta di un iceberg di
quello che si trova in mare e questo va
sicuramente a influenzare tutta la
catena alimentare che vada dal placton
fino alla noia all'essere umano e queste
queste plastiche si ammassano grazie
alle correnti degli oceani e formano
delle isole incredibilmente grandi la
più famosa il pacific trash vortex
nell'oceano pacifico ma non crediate che
sia un problema lontano da noi i punti
rossi sulla sulla carta del mediterraneo
sono significare le zone dove c'è
maggiore concentrazione di plastica nel
nostro nel nostro mare perché questo
perché per tanti anni la crescita
economica
gruppo delle società alla crescita
demografica ha giustificato qualunque
tipo di azione anche quelle contro il
nostro ambiente
la marina militare ha sempre creduto
però che è possibile uno sviluppo
sostenibile rispettoso dell'ambiente per
questo ha sviluppato tutta una serie di
progetti che vanno in questo senso
progetti che ci hanno fatto guadagnare
la l'appellativo di flotta verde del
mediterraneo e tra questi progetti c'è
sicuramente il progetto sauro che la
marina militare ha sposato come esempio
di sviluppo sostenibile e di sviluppo
rispettoso dell'ambiente soprattutto a
beneficio delle nostre future
generazioni
ma non voglio rubare altro tempo e
lascio la parola l'amico volta per
proseguire grazie
buongiorno per spiegarvi il progetto
sauro partirò con due esempi era la sera
del 10 aprile 1991 quando il traghetto
moby prince
uscendo dal porto di livorno andon
collisione con la petroliera agip
abruzzo e con conseguenze enormi dal
punto di vista ambientale inumane quel
giorno anzi quella notte 2.700
tonnellate di petrolio a causa della
collisione finirò mare incendiandosi
a causa dell'urto il cengio che si
propagò al traghetto moby prince 140
persone morirono bruciate sul traghetto
io fu chiamato a intervenire in quel
contesto la mia primo intervento di
quelle dimensioni e circa quattro ore
dopo ero sul posto è il mio ruolo era
team leader coordinavo 9 batte agli arti
inquinamento tutti questi batteri e
sicuramente lo ha dotato di un apparato
chiamato skimmer lo skimmer un apparato
un macchinario che serve per bonificare
gli specchi acquei contaminati da
idrocarburi questi apparati e ancora
oggi largamente utilizzati fin dalle
prime ore di lavoro di mostrar loro
limiti i limiti che oggi hanno
riscontrato in esperienze precedente più
piccoli e quella volta furono eclatanti
limiti dell'uso off shore cioè in mare
aperto in mare aperto non questi limiti
praticamente diventano come dicevo
eclatanti il petrolio in fiamme
a contatto può superficie marina si
solidifica va in una massa d'enza e
viscosa che catturava qualsiasi solido
galleggiante era era in questo per fitch
e questi solidi praticamente venivano
risucchiati dallo ski nero scheme si
bloccava quindi eravamo costruita
interrompere di lavoro il lavoro come se
questo non bastasse il posto di porto di
livorno esposta ovest è spesso un vento
proprio da ove scusava un'onda non
serviva che fosse uno da grossa john
onda di 50 centimetri faceva sì che
l'assetto dello skimmer non fosse più
quello parallelo cioè per recuperare ma
cominciato a ballare sul mare quindi non
solo non si recuperava ma anche il
prodotto che si recuperava quel poco
tornava nuovamente in mare poi il terzo
fatto l'urgenza quale era evitare di
contaminare la costa quindi cerchiamo ad
operare più rapidamente possibile bene
ci siamo accorti subito ma a milano già
accorto anche precedenza che se io
passavo a velocità di un nodo sempre per
questo motivo di assetto lo skimmer e
diciamo su quadrava non era più un
assetto quindi non vi purificava più
devo mori a passo d'uomo per bonificare
quindi il peso l'olio contaminò la posta
riprese ovviamente le conseguenze
classiche gli stessi problemi ma è anche
in maniera ancora molto ma molto più
eclatante è successo il 20 aprile 2010
quando durante le fasi finali di una
della trivellazione di un pozzo
petrolifero nel golfo del messico una
bolla di metano causò l'esplosione
l'esplosione incendio affondamento della
piattaforma deep water horizon è
ovviamente la rottura del tubo che
collegava era collegata al pozzo nei 106
giorni che questa apertura resto aperto
fra le 500 mila e 800 mila tonnellate di
greggio finirono in mare
una parte di queste 127 milioni di litri
invece spiaggia o perché ti ho questa
città precisa perché fu quello
recuperato dalle coste della louisiana
127 milioni di litri
una cosa anche gli undici persone
perirono importante verdi oltre all'uso
quindi per evitare questo spiaggiamento
per evitare tentare di evitare questo
spiaggiamento e poi ci fu
oltre all'uso degli skimmer furono usate
anche due tecniche che si rivedranno
ancora più dannose per la mia
il primo fu l'uso di solventi solventi
praticamente che proibiti in molti stati
alcuni laboratorio hanno definito
quattro volte più tossici del petrolio
stesso lato sistema fu il bar ming
insito cioè dal fuoco accumulare il
petrolio e dargli fuoco
questo cosa questo cosa abbiamo cosa
ottennero che una quantità enorme di gas
tossici andavano atmosfera un'alta
quantità enorme di residui soldi andò
asfaltare il fondale è praticamente
niente
la vita marina sul fondale ovviamente
morì questi esempi cosa cosa perché li
ho fatti perché ci sono le fa riflettere
sulla necessità fondamentale il petrolio
non deve essere né bruciato nel trattato
unicamente chimicamente il petrolio va
recuperato fondamentale per recuperarlo
quindi la velocità d'esecuzione la
velocità di bonifica e questa la prima
dote che un sistema di bonifica deve
avere provate ad immaginare un secondo
se quello che è successo nel golfo del
messico posti ci sono delle piattaforme
italiane che sono molto più vicino alla
costa che la nuova piattaforma deep
water polis
non solo ma noi siamo anche in un mare
chiuso le conseguenze sarebbero ancora
più devastanti questi esempi illustrano
con evidenza le tre problematicità
collegati agli scammer attualmente in
uso selettività velocità ridotta altezza
delle onde
cominciamo selettività di tutto sono
selettivi nel senso che recuperano
soltanto olio
se c'è un come dicevo prima un un pezzo
di plastica un pezzo di corda qualsiasi
cosa lo skimmer si blocca non funziona
più
va pulito ripristinato si ricominci a
operare il 3 skimmer che sono adatti per
i solidi come si può vedere come
soltanto i solidi quindi praticamente se
c'è del liquido il prodotto ricasca mare
il liquido primo momento torna in mare
il secondo problema è come dicevo prima
che la bonifica deve essere lenta cioè
una velocità operativa pressappoco
intorno a passo d'uomo
quindi affinché la politica abbia
successo il terzo il problema è
necessaria la calma
mare calmo
a riprova di questo sia andata a vedere
anche su internet senza cercato
l'immagine di uno skimmer in operatività
con moto mediamente mosso un moto ondoso
medio non esiste tutte le fotografie
sono commare assolutamente calmo guardi
come questo pavimento sauro a cronico di
sé anti pollution
julito rapidi o floor drainage rapid
offshore rapido mare aperto è un
brevetto e uno skimmer brevettato dalla
protezione civile nazionale
bevete rilasciato ad agosto 2014
concepito proprio per le operazioni
veloci e in zone di mare aperto oceani o
quello che volete e iran e risolvere i
tre problemi che abbiamo prima citato
come risolve unendo i punti di forza del
lloyd steam del 3 skimmer eliminandone i
limiti
infatti attraverso un semplicissimo
movimento di traslazione o meglio di
elevazione per tutto simile a una scala
mobile quella di uso quotidiano cominciò
che si prende aeroporti metropolitane
centri commerciali e i gradini possono
contemporaneamente recuperare plastica o
olio o praticamente è anche pratica il
centro di solidi anche solidi solidi
come come viene questo la superficie di
ogni gradino ogni faccia a due
componenti le spazzole per l'olio o le
microplastiche sotto delle punte
metalliche per gli stili di solidi
solidi anche di peso elevato
allo stesso modo sauro risolve il
problema della
le condizioni marine con l'aiuto di una
scaffalatura cioè sauro viene i
scatolato dentro una scaffalatura cosa
succede il moto ondoso al limite un
colpo dimaro noda può soltanto spingere
ancora più dentro il prodotto ma non lo
so c'è fuori perché è chiuso stesso
sistema stessa cosa per la velocità la
velocità stavolo risolve perché
avanzando quello che cattura la bocca
salirà ancora più su da tempo lo spazio
recuperarlo senza ricadere mare quindi
impedendo la fuoriuscita e proteggendo
contemporamente ciò che avviene
all'interno un esempio se prendiamo la
nave non grande e piccola larga 15 metri
ci mettiamo ci stiamo a sauro ai lati
praticamente una velocità di 10 nodi una
velocità ottima perché uno skimmer
abbiamo detto che lavora 12 nodi non si
lavora a 10 volte di più bene noi con
questo sistema
recuperiamo a 10 nodi e l'equivalente in
un'ora si bonifica in un'ora
l'equivalente di 60 campi di calcio sono
questi i numeri che ci fanno pensare ci
fanno riflettere ad ambire a obiettivi
fuori da mari italiani parlo del
pacifico e sportex quel quell'enorme
pietro piovra che sta strangolando
l'ecosistema qui c'è una foca ma ci
sarebbe migliaia di queste fotografie
qui cosa succede il caso della plastica
nei mari del mondo
inoltre punto di forza di sauro è che
non serve assolutamente costruire una
nave qualsiasi nave la prova è la nave
della marina militare la nave operativa
molto trasporto costiero che al quale
prima faceva tutto un altro lavoro
adesso diventerà la prima nave al mondo
per bonifica multipurpose quello che
state per vedere adesso è il video
perché dalle parole dalla carta siamo
passati ai fatti abbiamo costruito un
modello in scala con l'aiuto
dell'università di firenze abbiamo
scritto un modello in scala 1 50 di un
no di una nave a caso di un
rimorchiatore d altura o su premesse
quello che lavora sotto le piattaforme
che ci porta quindi i materiali a bordo
quindi la nave dal lavoro per le
piattaforme questo modello è stato
testato in vasca la presenza dei tecnici
della marina militare e non solo e a
seguito dell'esito positivo del test
la marina militare ha deciso di sposare
il progetto sauro mettendo a
disposizione una nave e siglando un
accordo di collaborazione con noi
la protezione civile nazionale e proprio
del progetto sauro quindi sarà per la
prima volta nella storia che una nave di
una marina militare operativa una
cooperativa della marina militare
diventerà la prima nave antinquinamento
multipurpose
grazie al progetto sauro e abbiamo un
adamantina un'enorme opportunità se
tutti insieme costruiamo scalino per
scalino quella scala mobile che ci farà
salire e poi finalmente potremo vedere
un oceano senza chiazze nere e sette
isole di plastica sfida ambientale unica
risanamento oceanico grazie